the the latest coronavirus insanity yeah
this is this is a shock I didn't know
that there you didn't know doing this
and think about how many is today right
and and and you're sitting right next to
me right mm-hmm
think about how many other people have
no idea what's going on with how bad the
corona virus is in the United
I'm sure a lot of people have no idea
they're coughing on stuff face no
leading all the so little you know
California is monitoring at least eighty
four hundred for signs of corona virus
as thirty three test positive for kovat
nineteen in the state including a
patient with unknown origin who took
four days to be screening for the
disease as they didn't fit the criteria
for infection and then they turned out
to have it yeah
and now we've got voluntary lockdowns
for seven hundred people in New York
it's too late man I'm sorry they're
gonna be they're gonna be by their door
they're gonna walk in from the from the
from the bodega grabbing a sandwich
they're gonna cough they're gonna push
the door open yup that thousands of
other people have pushed open and
thousands more will come and pushing it
last nine days nine days so I mean how
many people walk into a bodega every day
probably thousands eighty four hundred
people are being monitored for signs New
York and I saw Massachusetts I could be
wrong about Massachusetts see if you can
maybe maybe you can find something but I
saw that they were doing like a
voluntary lockdown so you've got Trump
right now trying to say it's gonna pass
it's gonna be okay and there's there's a
really obvious reason why I think he's
doing it and to an extent I can respect
it but I think he's playing it wrong
he's putting on look I get it man you
don't want people freaking out and you
don't want this check this out yeah this
didn't nuts the Dow Falls 1191 points
the most in history dude I was so I'm
sitting here working and I saw these
numbers and it's at 25 after because we
were at 29 or whatever yeah like a few
basically hi lately write you up and
been just like I'm pretty surprised I
wouldn't sell I think I think people are
crazy for selling because you know what
you know what you do like even after the
2008 Great Recession mm-hmm we were
covered yeah and then some so it's like
people panic and they sell everything
off and then a year goes by and it's
like imagine where you'd be if he just
did nothing
yeah you'd be better off like if you
think the world is going to end sure
like dough sell and then go take your
vacation in the Bahamas people are
freaking out though I think handling it
worse oh dude it's gonna get way worse
so this is apparently the worst
drop-offs it's the worst in history and
the closest thing was the Great
Recession but so let's do this let's
let's start with what's going on in
California cuz I think yeah I think we
better give some some context as to
what's happening yoga in America those
are you know checking his podcasts out
basically trying to do is like the first
segment was the international response
now we're trying to do like what's
happening here
so we got this the Daily Mail reports
California health officials are
monitoring eighty four hundred people
for coronavirus symptoms after their
arrival on domestic commercial flights
governor Gavin Newsom said on Thursday
the state currently has only about two
hundred test kits an inadequate number
but has been in constant contact with
federal agencies that have promised to
send a fresh supply of kits in coming
days he said at a news briefing in
Sacramento California officials had 33
people had tested positive for the virus
there but five had since left the state
on Wednesday California reported the
first known case of the virus in the
United States of unknown origin the
patient had not recently traveled to an
area with a reported outbreak and was
not exposed to another known infected
person dr. Sonya Angel California State
Public Health Officer said local state
and federal health investigators were
contacting and isolating individuals who
may have been exposed to the patient in
what would be the first u.s. case of
local community spread so I think that's
I think that's the most important bits
about it yeah here's here's what I want
to get to California can't possibly test
all of these people no way they've got
80 400 and 200 tests and where are these
tests coming from federal government I
know where are they getting it I'm not
making them in China that was a good
question it is they applied for a
testing because that one dude escaped oh
okay okay like let's let's get let's get
serious man some dude was was in a
quarantine and they tested him let him
go and then his tests came back and
that's actually positive somebody let an
infect
do out of quarantine because they did
the test wrong or whatever Wow so it's
like dude you know what man
I kind of feel like human collective
incompetence is getting worse every day
what kind of razor was that what yeah so
look man when I heard that New York what
can you find it filling up there were
700 in New York that were voluntarily
quarantined and then I just pulled out
600 Massachusetts are being watched for
possible symptoms voluntary quarantine
in New York yeah and monitoring in
Massachusetts so I I think there's
phases that voluntary quarantine is like
oh you know I might be sick so I'm just
gonna stay at home and then what's going
on in Massachusetts is they're keeping
an eye on them for possibly having
symptoms of coronavirus and then beyond
that you get like quarantine everything
so we're looking at we're getting close
to just go on there full-on quarantine
stoked it's gonna happen like it's gonna
happen it seems like it has to happen
well the crazy thing to me is the people
who believe it will never happen right
like have you looked at Europe man so
many of these complacent people being
like oh it's fine nothing ever happens
is I've driven around Europe it's so
easy to just drive from country to
country to country and it's blowing up
in Italy people drive around they just
cannot they thought they thought they'd
come yeah after it blew 600 more cases
and Italy well you're like oh we missed
these ones oh sweet
the Pope sick that means that hope is
sick oh really yeah and he was going
around shaking hands and like dude all
of it it'll Italy has these infections
going crazy yeah it's not a pope sick I
mean and that they have a long
incubation period so it's all hitting
Italy now but it's been there already
for a while that's what I'm talking
about so driving around driving through
Italy people do that they come through
Italy go up into France
you know Switzerland whatever it's do
and it's gonna spread u.s. stock markets
drop goldman sachs projects zero growth
from coronavirus zero growth so what's
gonna happen man it's gonna keep
dropping you think I mean all those
factories are shutting down so like
product isn't moving
so yeah it's basically all the wheels
that that that earth you know has that
humans use like this whole wheel just
out yeah it's like the whole system
can't work if this wheels gone and then
all of a sudden this wheels gone to now
now all of a sudden foods not being
moved around like the planet has were
used to then like the stock exchange
dies so credit isn't used the same like
we we're on a verge of something that's
kind of scary here I don't if this so
swine flu was bad it was really bad I
didn't know how about was how bad it was
I didn't know either there was his
animation was that bad yeah like 13
million people 80,000 80,000 dead yeah I
wish we could show that animation yeah
well we could have pulled it up I don't
have it but uh they they had a point
five percent mortality rate and that was
a serious deal yeah and it wasn't even
growing as fast as coronaviruses is
spreading it wasn't spreading as fast
and that was after 145 days you know you
know what man like that was 212 it
reached like 13 or so million Soto's was
finally kind of controlled and I think
it wasn't that big in the US that was
probably why we didn't really think
about it yeah it was a lot in Mexico I
think but the World Health Organization
has been worried about something called
disease X for a long time and it's just
a hypothetical disease that breaks
quarantine moves fast has a long
incubation period and can is airborne
and can be on the surfaces for so long
period and like sounds really familiar
yeah they're like this might be it
this might be it so now we're looking at
its here in the United States it's it's
getting worse in the United States
mm-hmm and so what I always try
stressing everybody is like take a look
at this map right here total US cases is
60 yeah I remember when Italy was like
seven it was like oh he's got some
people who are tourists we locked him
down now they're freaking out now it's
across the board you know but now the US
market is tanking so I don't know you
know like there there's a lot of people
who are extremely predictable yeah and
that's the biggest problem in the market
that people are gonna exploit this and
I'll tell you what right now many smart
people are laughing about it everybody
who's selling and driving the market
down they're laughing because they're
gonna buy the dip and they're gonna come
out in a year and they're gonna have ten
times this what you think they're also
selling to then buy and like no no
what do you mean I think there are a
bunch of people who have no idea how the
system works are hearing about
coronavirus freaking out yeah and then
being and then going to their accounts
and selling and they're gonna regret it
they're absolutely gonna regret it look
if like I had a friend a long time ago
who had a bunch of money in some stocks
there's like 10 years ago and I was like
what stocks do you have and she was like
I rather keep it private and I was like
aren't you worried that like the stocks
could go down and you lose that money
would you rather just have that money
and like do something with it and she
laughed and was like if these stocks go
down then everyone else has gone down a
lot worse and so I don't I never really
learned about what she was investing in
but the general idea is like if you
think that the stock market will not
recover beyond where it was at now yeah
then you basically think human
civilization is over because every
single time has been a hit we've
recovered and then some and if you just
kept what you had it would have
recovered yeah so when you panic and
freak out you don't help anybody yeah I
see that dip and I'm just like oh maybe
I should buy some stock right exactly
like a opportunity right you're selling
yeah now the price is finally down so a
lot of people who wanted to get in yeah
well now's your opportunity that's true
it's it's unfortunate really it's gonna
go down further though I think so yeah
what's up with this Nebraska having 13
Oh
evac and yeah they brought evacuees
there I think they brought them in from
other places or well yes so have the
most cases have coronavirus now
quarantined though in a mill in the
middle of the country okay that makes
sense right yeah I suppose how crazy
what remember when we were saying like
it's really crazy that they're bringing
back these evacuees from these other
countries yeah what are they doing cuz
Trump got mad like how stupid you have
to be yeah well let's let's just bring
the Americans home but they're infected
why it'll be crazy why would you do that
what if like this gets so bad that the
elections get postponed because it's
actually the Democrats who are screaming
about is where does the order the book
to direct in 1551
yeah yes security president if you won I
mean it does make sense if there is such
a dramatic death toll like having to
like an election when people are dying
across the country
the issue is putting it off right isn't
it's it's it's right but here's the
issue if in a month mm-hmm the u.s. sees
it as bad as like China did yeah cuz
like in January they're like there are
14 people with the respiratory on this
yeah and now it's February like they're
81,000 yeah if in the United States
we're looking at 60 and in a month from
now we're looking at eighty one thousand
it would be really dumb to have
elections not because you know it's
because we don't people all going into
the same room together and I'll touching
the same things exactly but that's but
not having an election is freaky right
and there's people that are malicious
enough to lick elevator buttons what are
they gonna do with the polling booth
like the pen no they'll spit on the the
button for the the candidate they don't
[Laughter]
on Twitter there was a post where people
were attacking Trump over you know the
CDC and stuff and the comments were
bonkers man ruin it was people saying
like the good news is it'll all be his
supporters who get it because they don't
believe in science and a whole bunch of
other stuff hoping that the virus wipes
out Trump in his and his voters and I'm
like what is he will dude that's a
terrible thing to wish on anyone like
like really what yeah or healing people
we're just sickness and suffering it's
it's crazy to me how vile people can be
yeah it's it's gross but to see all of
these people just saying like good they
deserve it it's like I don't have
nothing to do with you people you people
freak me out yeah like my thing is
always like I look forward to all of you
from left to right to get to being
healthy and surviving so we can get back
to arguing on the internet we're
supposed to be it's what I say about a
lot of things there's a holes in every
different facet of humans that's it
they're everywhere and there's there's
good people everywhere in all races and
factions it doesn't matter
here's the cool guys and the ales don't
you know I think it is there are people
slightly center-left that are good smart
rational people that hold their ground
there are center-right people who are
good smart rational people who hold
their ground and then there are good
smart rational people who kind of bounce
back and back and forth here
good arguments and having arguments and
kind of like hey that's a good point
yeah and now we're looking at where well
the left used to own the good smart
people in center left and now they have
kind of started moving over because the
left is pushing people out and getting
crazier it's that line you showed me
where this is Center right though yeah
right the right is here and they've
pretty much been there and then the left
is just slowly slowly Frazee right there
further from the middle than the other
side exactly it's like you know what
that makes sense so so now it's like the
people that used to be the sane rational
left mm-hmm
are now centrists right yeah it's like
though it's like the weirdest thing I
don't even how do we get into this
because people are our mean I guess I
just can't believe you know look I think
we can we can finish beating the horse
on this one yeah
it's here in the United States the bomb
the voluntary quarantines are the first
step in the mandatory quarantines yeah
if you live in New York City God have
mercy
surrounded there it is crowded it's
always great and I mean I I left New
York about under a year ago but I didn't
take the subways often I skated but
there's some times that I had to take
the subway and it I've lived in New York
for 15 years so it went from like you
can always get on the subway when there
was a train there to having people push
ya in and that's a normal thing and I'd
be like I'll take an anxious one I'll
take the next one it's crazy
I'll take that action could you imagine
right now saying no nobody but think
about that so a lot of you might not be
from New York City you might understand
this you literally are
shoulder-to-shoulder yeah crammed in
because I don't push you into the dark
enclosed so they can get in they do that
in like Japan and China and stuff mm-hmm
yeah this is how I imagine well I've
only I haven't ridden on the subway I've
only been to concerts but I can imagine
that crush is kind of like being in a
concert there's no it is exactly now
it's not exactly like being in the now
and on the line here's what I want you
imagine that a concert yeah you go down
and you're getting on the what I don't
know the our train right you're you're
in Manhattan it's really really crowded
you're all jammed in you're right in the
middle of the train there's no easy way
to move around and the only way to get
out is for everyone else
move the train starts going and they say
this train will now be running Express
from 29th Street to 100 or whatever yeah
and then the guy next she goes oh oh I
just got back from Hong Kong and I am
not feeling well what do you do you
start screaming and violently shaking in
the train grove and you're gonna be on
that train for five minutes five minutes
no it's gonna take longer than that yeah
and then sorry this train is waiting for
a train oh yeah you get even the latest
stuff did the infrastructure is so
brutal it's falling apart but it's like
the train stops there is a delay ahead
yeah that's right I always skated it was
awesome but nobody to do it in all
seriousness though like when you've got
700 people in voluntary quarantine
mm-hmm how many people are gonna bake
man I want pizza yeah I got it I gotta
get those vegan wings man I'm gonna go
pick them up we can go to blackbird
they're amazing but where's my point
they go outside they're like it's one
train stop just persons coughing on the
train yeah routed now what a thousand
people just get coronavirus I'm sure it
fit once it hits New York it's gonna
explode dude because it's gonna be if it
hits New York and they find it that and
it's there that means it's been there
you know other people have it well what
but they're telling people to quarantine
the lockdown
yeah so what's the chance that one of
them actually has it well they're afraid
that that could happen and they're right
to be smart and prep like that because
dude I mean we we we have not had a
major catastrophe at this population
level before dencity and it's 2020 what
happened in 1920 it was 1820 was 1920
spanning 1720 wasn't they're always on
the 29:18 before that it's like pretty
consistently yeah same with us for a
second listen New York City's population
density is absurd it's more than the
whole country of Sweden yeah Wow
yeah whole country yep so imagine what
happens when you know the the the the
feces hit the fan yeah gotta keep a
language family friendly even though
it's all kind of gross yeah when it when
it when it when it when it really gets
that point it's like it's gonna hit
everyone knew you're what it's so packed
there
no when the water stops when the food
stops what do they do people are gonna
be fleeing like crazy that's what I'm
saying if you're on Long Island if
you're in Brooklyn like may God have
mercy on your not only that is their
eggs aliens of people going through New
York it's it's the shopping day of the
world they worship one of them you know
it's they would have to shut the trains
down if they found the airport if they
find one coronavirus case yep
they're gonna shut the trains down will
they I don't know I don't think so cuz
the economy man yet I know New York
always wants to keep the stores open yo
always if I think sandy hit and they
lost like two billion dollars in two
days or something and like revenue from
the millions and millions of tourists
that come in every single day every day
there's tourists coming in so they're
gonna lose all that and they don't get
it they don't want that's Facebook
shutting it down shutting it down
New York everything fine ride this you
know come shop at the stores I think no
cases here I think the best thing I can
do when we're recognizing the
possibility is something like this
hitting New York now there's no
confirmed cases but to quote a very
famous a speaker and order by your gold
people the end is coming they're coming
with the crown I'm just kidding don't
buy gold I don't know if well it's gonna
help you water it's gonna be more more
valuable than gold it is no I do
actually administer sincerely like yeah
Gold has its place for sure like because
III have some silver some people sent me
sulfur I have a little bits of gold you
guys can send me silver too if you think
so and gold
hey yet at the same address no but I
think in terms of preparation like what
you want to do in the case things get
really really bad I'm not convinced that
if the apocalypse happens gold will help
you but I do think if the you if
confidence in the US government goes
down Gold will definitely help you like
so long as the the global economic
system continues yeah Gold is good it's
great to have mmm because like if
confidence in the US dollar goes down
then you have your gold which keeps its
value it's gone up right it goes up and
sort of silver yeah but when it comes to
chaos in the streets and people like
knocking over old women to steal the
last can of beans that's when you want
to have food and water I mean and
basically happened I mean they're not
knocking over old no like I got punched
another guy yeah the shelves are empty
except for except for some dry pasta
pasta well that's my door today it's
like in business as usual in Sydney
Australia's fine in Australia the Prime
Minister said pandemic is possible and
people rushed the stores I think the
only like you were to Sam's Club earlier
yeah I think the only reason you didn't
see a horde of people stripping the
shelves is because trumps had calm down
everything's gonna be fine that's true
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you